Venez, Père Pedro !
J'arrive, mon enfant.
Vous êtes européen !
Que faites-vous ?
Arrêtez !
Comment osez-vous ?
Arrêtez ça !
Laissez-le tranquille, brute !
Pour l'amour de Dieu, arrêtez !
Tout va bien mon fils,
reposez-vous.
Vous avez traversé
une rude épreuve,
mais vous êtes ici en sécurité.
Où suis-je, mon Père ?
Comment suis-je venu ici ?
Quand vous aurez mangé,
je vous expliquerai tout.
Prenez ce breuvage, mon fils.
Ce sont des herbes médicinales.
Mon Père...
à qui dois-je la liberté ?
À la demoiselle Maria De Torres.
Elle a payé pour votre liberté.
Je dois la remercier,
et bien sûr, trouver une manière
de la rembourser.
Je ne réclame peut-être pas
de remboursement ?
Je peux désirer vous garder
comme esclave.
Après tout...
j'ai déboursé une jolie somme.
Certainement pas...
aussi jolie que vous, madame.
On m'a prévenue
que seul le Diable,
peut être aussi charmeur.
Êtes-vous le diable,
Senor De Gama ?
Certes non, madame,
mais un homme...
extrêmement heureux
d'être en vie.
Ces effets
appartiennent à mon père.
Il ne sont guère
de la dernière mode,
mais ils devraient vous convenir.
Veuillez m'excuser,
je dois vous quitter.
Mon père m'attend.
Si je puis vous être utile ?
Si vous êtes certain
d'être rétabli,
je serais ravie
que vous m'accompagniez.
Cela vous donnerait l'occasion
de rencontrer mon père.
Avec grand plaisir.
Que fait votre père ici ?
Il est au service du Roi.
Il est chargé
de la construction d'un fort,
pour protéger la ville.
C'est là que nous allons.
Votre Majesté !
Le Roi de Lanna a refusé
de payer son tribut.
Il vous fait envoyer la tête
de votre collecteur.
Vous êtes rayonnante,
ma Reine !
Cela fait si longtemps...
que le Roi et moi
n'avons eu un instant d'intimité,
que je veux que celui-ci...
reste inoubliable.
Plus haut votre garde,
mon Prince !
Oui, excellent !
Mère !
M'avez-vous vu ?
Avez-vous vu
comme j'ai bien combattu ?
Oui, mon fils !
Admirablement !
Comme un vrai guerrier !
Reprenons, mon Prince.
Votre Majesté.
Le Roi m'envoie vous informer,
qu'il ne pourra vous recevoir,
pour cause
d'une grave raison d'État.
Remercie le Roi,
et assure-le...
que je suis son humble servante.
- Votre Majesté...
- Sortez ! M'entendez-vous ?
Il me traite comme
une vulgaire courtisane !
Quelque jour...
je lui ferai payer
son inconséquence !
J'en fais le voeu formel !
Permettez-moi de vous aider,
madame.
Merci.
Venez, suivez-moi.
Avec plaisir.
Par ici...
Père nous attend.
- Les fondations...
- Voici l'homme dont je vous ai parlé,
- Fernando De Gama.
- Un instant.
Mon père, Senor De Torres.
Mon cher ami...
êtes-vous souffrant ?
Vous avez l'air
d'avoir vu un fantôme !
Tout va bien.
Asseyez-vous.
Merci.
Seigneur, bénissez ce repas.
Grâces vous soient rendues. Amen.
Eh bien...
Bienvenue,
Senor De Gama.
J'espère que les conditions
de votre séjour,
seront infiniment meilleures
que celles de votre arrivée.
Moi aussi, monsieur.
Alors...
qu'est-ce qui vous amène
en Asie ?
Je suis un soldat.
Vraiment ?
Un soir dans une taverne,
j'ai croisé mon ancien colonel,
qui louait des mercenaires,
pour le Roi de Burma.
Je me suis engagé.
Je comprends.
Le Roi de Burma
est l'ennemi juré de ce peuple.
En fait...
si vous n'aviez fait naufrage,
et été capturé par les arabes,
vous auriez certainement accosté,
en tant qu'envahisseur.
Regardez !
L'Émissaire du Roi !
Que peut-il vouloir ?
Bienvenue, Votre Excellence.
Nul doute que vous venez...
constater la progression
des travaux de votre fort.
Non,Senor De Torres.
Une autre affaire m'amène.
" Sa Majesté,
portant grand respect,
aux valeurs guerrières...
du peuple portugais,
ordonne...
que tous vos hommes valides,
le rejoignent
dans une guerre contre
le renégat Royaume de Lanna."
Je vous prie...
d'assurer Sa Majesté,
que la communauté portugaise,
servira le Roi
avec un indéfectible dévouement.
Nous partons.
Au Palais.
Tout le monde quitte le chantier !
Préparez vos chevaux !
- Antonio !
- Monsieur ?
J'ai besoin de toi.
Il nous faut tout organiser.
Pour le cas...
où je ne reviendrais pas.
En ce jour...
nous allons au-devant de l'armée
de ce chien de traître...
qui s'est autoproclamé...
Roi de Lanna !
Cet esclave...
a assassiné tous les hommes,
femmes et enfants de la cité !
Alors, courageux guerriers...
aiguisez vos sabres,
aiguisez vos esprits,
et donnez prompte mort
à tous nos ennemis !
En marche !... À l'assaut !
Si le Roi pouvait...
livrer bataille chaque jour,
je serais l'homme...
le plus comblé !
Pas si fort !
On va nous entendre.
Qui pourrait nous entendre ?
Ne t'inquiète de rien.
Qu'as-tu ?
Es-tu malade ?
J'appelle le médecin de la Cour.
Es-tu fou ?
Qu'il sache
que tu es avec moi ?
Veux-tu connaître
une mort affreuse ?
Non...
Bien sûr que non.
Ce sont des nausées ?
Je ne suis pas malade.
Mes malaises sont dus...
au bébé que j'attends !
Comprends-tu ?
Un enfant ?
Oui... notre bébé !
Qu'allons-nous faire ?
Je vais en finir avec le Roi !
Je ne veux plus me cacher.
Ni vivre dans la crainte.
Nous allons diriger
le Royaume ensemble !
Fais-moi confiance.
Ils ignorent
quelle femme je suis.
Mais bientôt...
ils le sauront !
Père, soyez prudent !
Ne pleure pas.
Si je tombe,
prie pour mon âme.
Tambour !
Frappe ton instrument !
En avant !
Fernando !
Vous avez fière allure
dans votre armure.
Je voulais vous remercier.
Pour tous vos bienfaits.
Au cas où...
En cas de malheur.
Dieu nous en garde !
Je prierai pour vous.
D'ailleurs, il me faudra
récupérer mon investissement.
Alors soyez prudent !
Je le serai.
Avec l'aide de Dieu,
votre investissement
vous sera restitué...
intact.
Majesté...
10 000 hommes
viennent grossir vos rangs.
Excellent.
Vraiment excellent.
Je suis si heureux
que tu m'aies rejoint, jeune frère.
En route !
Oui !
Quoi ?
Hé, le portugais,
tu veux essayer ?
Je crois qu'il veut
partager sa nourriture.
Quoi ?
Goûte !
J'en veux bien un petit peu.
Aucun goût !
C'est pas mauvais.
C'est du rat.
Délicieux !
On va s'amuser avec ton coq !
Il vaut mieux les laisser,
Fernando.
Père ! Père !
Du calme, mon fils !
Je suis là.
Pardonnez-moi, mon Père.
Oui, mon fils.
Juste un cauchemar.
- Désolé, mon Père.
- Ce n'est rien.
Je n'étais pas vraiment endormi,
je somnolais.
Le sommeil est difficile
avant une bataille.
Soyons pieux, mon fils.
Ayons foi
en la toute puissance de Dieu.
Ton père a dû t'apprendre cela,
comme le mien l'a fait.
Vous avez eu de la chance.
Mon père m'a été enlevé
très jeune.
Assassiné par un homme
qu'il croyait son ami.
On dit souvent...
que les yeux
sont le reflet de l'âme.
Je lis dans ton regard...
qu'il est rempli
de ton désir de vengeance.
Libère-t-en, Fernando.
Ou il va te consumer vivant.
Ne laisse pas l'homme
qui a pris la vie de ton père,
prendre aussi la tienne.
Plus facile à dire qu'à faire.
Car ma première pensée
est pour lui...
à mon réveil.
Ainsi que ma dernière,
avant de m'endormir.
À propos de sommeil,
il serait sage
d'en prendre un peu,
car demain...
il nous faudra avoir
les idées claires.
Bonne nuit, Fernando.
Bonne nuit, mon Père.
Soldats du Portugal !
Faites votre devoir !
Valeureux soldats,
voici venir l'ennemi,
les Lanna !
Senor De Torres,
soyez le bienvenu.
Mes félicitations
pour cette bataille victorieuse.
J'ai accouru dès réception
de l'ordre de Votre Majesté.
Depuis quand me servez-vous,
Senor De Torres ?
Je vous sers, Madame...
depuis près de neuf années,
à mon arrivée dans ce Royaume.
Puis-je présumer,
que Votre Majesté aurait...
un problème qui requiert...
de la discrétion, et...
une infinie délicatesse.
Mon problème...
ainsi que vous l'avez
finement deviné,
est extrêmement délicat,
et considérable.
Cependant...
grâce à la petite fortune
qui récompensera votre zèle,
je suis persuadée...
que vous assumerez votre tâche.
Votre Majesté dispose
de grands pouvoirs de persuasion.
Quels sont vos souhaits ?
Hey, le portugais !
Je peux m'asseoir ?
Je t'en prie.
Je m'appelle Tong.
Merci de m'avoir sauvé la vie.
Je serais mort, sans ton aide.
Non, ce n'est rien.
Ça me fait plaisir.
Fernando De Gama.
Je suis un paysan.
J'ai une femme, et deux enfants.
Tu as une femme ?
Non.
Les thaïlandaises,
sont très belles.
J'en connais beaucoup.
Je peux te présenter ?
Pourquoi pas ?
Tu es bon au sabre.
Moi, c'est la hache.
Viens, je vais te montrer.
Très bien Gama,
à ton tour maintenant.
C'est une tribu du Sud.
Aucun conflit ne nous oppose.
Quelle relation avec Lanna ?
Pourquoi m'attaquent-ils ?
Étrange, en effet.
Je me renseignerai
de retour en ville.
Vous êtes deux valeureux guerriers.
Gama, c'est le Roi !
Vous serez récompensés.
Et promus au rang
de ma Garde Personnelle.
Prépare-toi à marcher,
mon frère.
Nous rentrons aujourd'hui.
Tong !
Comment vas-tu ?
Content de te revoir.
Voici ma femme, Mallee.
Mon fils, Ha Fa.
Et ma fille, Chloe.
C'est Maria.
Ravie de vous connaître.
Permettez-moi de vous présenter
le Père Pedro.
Venez manger quelque chose
avec votre famille.
- Merci, mon Père.
- Suivez-moi.
À plus tard, Gama.
Au revoir. Enchantée.
Me ferez-vous l'honneur
de danser avec moi ?
Je peux essayer.
La communauté portugaise...
souhaite bienvenue à nos vaillants
compagnons d'armes japonais.
Venez festoyer avec nous.
Le menton haut.
Combien de fois te l'ai-je dit ?
C'est dangereux.
Si on nous voyait ?
Crois-moi...
J'ai l'art de me fondre dans la nuit
comme une ombre.
Personne ne m'a vu venir.
Ça n'a plus d'importance.
J'ai parlé au Roi,
et il m'a donné la permission,
d'engager un nouvel
Administrateur de Cour.
En quoi
est-ce une bonne nouvelle ?
Pour la raison...
que tu es mon nouvel
Administrateur de Cour.
Et tu as un nouveau titre.
Kun Chinaran.
De la sorte,
tu peux venir à mon palais
à ta guise.
Je peux venir à ma guise ?
Le Senor De Torres
vous attend chez lui.
Veuillez m'excuser, messieurs.
J'adore danser, pas vous ?
La décision vous revient.
Mon information est sûre.
Excusez-moi.
Fernando, j'ai quelque chose
à vous montrer.
Capitaine.
À demain matin.
N'est-ce pas magnifique ?
C'est magique !
Regardez, Maria.
Cette multitude !
Ce fut une soirée exquise.
Vous dansez divinement.
Vous êtes indulgente.
J'ai deux pieds gauches.
Vous semblez troublé, subitement.
Vous ai-je contrarié ?
Je suis sûr que vous connaissez...
mes sentiments envers vous.
- Fernando, je...
- S'il vous plaît !
Vous souvenez-vous de
ce capitaine de marine,
tout à l'heure à la fête ?
Oui, pourquoi ?
Qui est-il ?
Il est le patron...
du Delgado ,
un navire marchand de Lisbonne.
Il part pour Goa
à la marée du matin.
J'embarque avec lui.
Pourquoi ?
Je recherche un homme.
De mon passé.
Je l'ai recherché toute ma vie.
Selon une information,
il est à Goa.
Je ne comprends pas.
Ce doit être pénible pour vous.
Mais il s'agit d'une affaire
que je dois régler.
Voudrez-vous...
m'attendre ?
Vous me proposez...
un bien cruel marché !
Si c'est une allusion
à l'argent engagé pour moi,
je vous rembourserai.
Sachez que je faisais allusion
à mon coeur,
et non à ma bourse !
Je ne voulais pas vous offenser,
pardonnez ma grossièreté !
Je suis satisfait
de nos arrangements.
Maria...
je ne t'espérais pas si tôt
à la maison.
Rentre donc,
j'ai d'excellentes nouvelles.
Merci Senor Fernando,
d'avoir raccompagné ma fille.
- Maria, je...
- Je devrais vous inviter,
mais la famille avant tout !
Maria...
Il faut que nous parlions.
Rejoignez-moi au port à l'aube !
Qu'ai-je fait ?
Pourquoi suis-je aussi stupide ?
Père, c'était impoli de votre part.
Désolé mon enfant,
trop absorbé dans mes pensées.
Assieds-toi.
J'ai d'excellentes nouvelles.
Quel est ton voeu le plus cher ?
Visiter le Portugal.
Exactement.
Dans peu de temps,
nous irons au Portugal.
Pas pour visiter,
mais nous y installer.
J'aurai assez de fortune,
pour acheter la plus belle
maison de Lisbonne.
Et tu auras les plus belles robes
dont tu peux rêver.
Puis un jour...
un prince de notre pays
nous rendra visite,
et dès qu'il te verra,
il tombera amoureux,
et me demandera ta main.
Et si je le juge
assez prestigieux pour toi,
je l'autoriserai à te passer...
l'anneau de mariage
de ta mère au doigt.
Ainsi ma vie sur cette terre
n'aura pas été vaine.
C'est merveilleux, Père.
Mais comment ?
C'est à portée de main.
Disons simplement que...
après tant d'années
de dur labeur, et...
de bons et loyaux services,
je vais enfin être récompensé.
Sois prudent, Fernando !
Chargez ces sacs à bord !
Je n'ai pas pu te quitter.
Au-delà de cette limite,
les hommes
sont strictement interdits.
En tant que serviteurs
da la Garde Personnelle du Roi,
votre devoir
est de faire observer cette loi.
Entrée interdite.
Pousse-toi,
ou je te fais décapiter.
Dégage l'entrée !
- Laisse-moi passer !
- Arrière !
Que se passe-t-il ?
Il est mon Administrateur.
Et il a un titre,
Kun Chinaran.
Ce qui lui donne totale autorité,
d'aller et venir dans mes quartiers
à sa guise.
Je vous prie de m'excuser,
Majesté.
Je l'ignorais.
Moi aussi, Majesté.
Vous le savez, maintenant.
Venez, Kun Chinaran.
Gardes !... Gardes !
Gardes !
Abaisse ton sabre.
Abaisse ton sabre !
Jette-le !
Ton couteau.
Doucement.
Quelqu'un à ma Cour...
souhaite ma mort.
Je vous charge...
de découvrir quelles sont
les vipères dans mon nid !
Et ramenez-les moi !
Mortes ou vives !
Retirez-vous.
Je crois savoir
qui est derrière ce complot.
Que se passe-t-il ?
Qui êtes-vous ?
Où allez-vous ?
Fernando ?
Que fais-tu ?
Que se passe-t-il ?
Ce n'est pas
une visite de courtoisie, Maria.
J'ai une affaire urgente
avec ton père.
Peux-tu me dire où il est ?
Il est au fort.
Qu'y a-t-il de si urgent ?
Gama...
Jette un coup d'oeil.
On a trouvé ça...
caché sous le plancher.
Que se passe-t-il, Fernando ?
Mon père est-il accusé
de quoi que ce soit ?
Si c'est le cas, dis-moi de quoi !
Tu ignores bien des choses
sur ton père.
Tu viens d'arriver.
Que peux-tu savoir
sur mon père ?
Je sais cela.
Ton acte de naissance.
Comme tu peux le lire...
le nom est De Favier,
et non De Torres.
Désolé, Maria.
Je ne comprends pas.
C'est impossible !
Emportez le coffret.
Gama !... Attends !
Reste ici...
jusqu'à mon retour.
Yai Jun !
Où te caches-tu, vieille sorcière ?
Montre-toi à ma vue !
C'est bien vous, Votre Excellence ?
Il y a si longtemps,
que vous n'avez fait appel
à mes services, Votre Altesse !
Que puis-je pour vous servir ?
J'ai grand besoin d'un poison,
qui puisse tuer instantanément.
Indécelable au goût.
Soyez sans inquiétude, ma Reine !
J'ai votre affaire !
Parfait.
Oh, c'est brûlant !
Absolument parfait !
Il faut que je l'enveloppe.
Je suppose...
que tu auras conscience
de ma très grande générosité,
pour te garder
de laisser aller ta langue.
Sinon, sois assurée,
vieille femme...
de connaître le pire !
C'est une bien belle épingle,
que vous avez là, Votre Altesse.
J'en ai toujours désiré
une semblable.
Si cela te fait tant plaisir,
prends-la.
Oh, merci !... Merci !
Merci beaucoup !
L'épingle et les pièces d'or,
je suis riche !
Je suis riche !
Occupe-toi d'elle !
Il est temps que je trouve
un nouveau terrier.
Ou j'ai bien peur d'être la femme
la plus riche du cimetière !
- Senor De Torres, je crois...
- Ils viennent pour moi.
Senor De Torres, où allez-vous ?
Au nom du Roi, arrêtez-vous !
Senor De Torres !
Ou devrais-je dire...
Pedro De Favier ?
Heureux que ce nom
vous soit familier !
Le mien vous l'est peut-être aussi.
De Gama...
est le nom de jeune fille
de ma mère.
De Monterio
est celui de mon père.
Votre vieil associé.
L'homme...
que vous avez assassiné !
Je savais t'avoir déjà vu.
Les yeux !
Tu as les yeux de ton père.
Le même regard accusateur !
Et vous, monsieur...
- Celui d'un meurtrier !
- Tu te trompes !
Je n'ai pas assassiné ton père,
mon garçon.
Je l'ai tué,
mais pas assassiné.
Je vous ai vu !
Vu de mes propres yeux !
Je n'avais que 8 ans,
mais je vous ai vu clairement !
Ton père et moi
avons grandi ensemble.
Deux jeunes têtes brûlées
d'aristocrates !
Sans un sou en poche !
On conspirait, on intriguait,
on jouait !
Et on buvait !
On était ivres cette nuit-là.
Je ne me souviens même plus
de l'objet de notre querelle !
Ton père a sorti son couteau,
et j'ai tenté de m'enfuir.
On s'est battus,
et le couteau s'est planté en lui !
Il aurait pu aussi bien
se planter en moi !
Je suis un fugitif depuis lors.
Toujours à regarder
par-dessus mon épaule,
qui arrive dans mon dos,
pour me ramener au pays.
Je dois encore m'enfuir.
Laisse-moi passer,
mon garçon.
Monsieur !
Vous ne fuirez plus !
Sur ordre du Roi,
je vous arrête !
- Ne m'oblige pas à te frapper !
- Je vous somme...
d'abaisser votre épée, monsieur !
Dernière sommation !
Pour la dernière fois,
je te somme...
de me laisser partir.
Je ne suis pas votre valet,
monsieur !
En ce cas, voyons si tu peux mourir
comme un homme !
Pourquoi ruiner votre vie ?
Et celle de votre fille ?
N'est-ce pas évident ?
C'était notre chance !
La rançon d'un Roi !
J'aurais pu rentrer à Lisbonne !
Racheter ma place
dans la bonne société !
J'aurais vécu comme un roi.
Et Maria, comme une princesse !
Maintenant, à cause de toi...
cela ne se fera pas !
Je vous le demande
une nouvelle fois.
Jetez votre épée.
Vous êtes encerclé.
Tu as raison.
Toute fuite est impossible.
Ne faites pas cela.
Ne faites pas cela !
Attention, Gama !
Allons-y !
C'est fini...
enfin fini !
Maria...
Dis-lui que je l'aime.
Tu l'aimes, toi aussi.
Je l'ai lu dans tes yeux.
Prends ça.
À toi de veiller sur elle.
Donne-lui cette bague.
Dis-lui...
que je te l'ai confiée.
Elle comprendra.
Pousse-toi de là.
Il nous le fallait vivant.
Il est clair qu'il n'a pas agi seul.
Ce qui signifie...
que la vie du Roi
est toujours menacée ?
Viens, Gama.
Cet or est à moi !
- Halte ! Que se passe-t-il ?
- Donnez ! C'est mon argent !
Elle a des pièces d'or.
Elle a dû les voler.
Fais voir.
- Fais-moi voir !
- C'est à moi !
- Donne !
- Vous n'avez pas le droit !
Ce sont les mêmes pièces
que celles du Senor De Torres.
Elles sont à moi !
À moi !
Fortune toute neuve ?
Où les as-tu trouvées,
vieille femme ?
Regarde ça !
Je crois que c'est le sceau
de la Reine.
C'est son effigie.
Comment tu l'as eue ?
- Tu l'as volée ?
- C'est aussi à moi !
Non, je ne l'ai pas volée !
Elle me l'a donnée !
Tu ne parais pas être
une amie de la Reine.
Alors, dis-moi la vérité,
ou on t'emmène au palais !
Je ne peux pas aller au palais !
La Reine me ferait tuer !
Réponds à cette question.
Pourquoi la Reine
voudrait-elle te tuer ?
Viens ici !
J'ai besoin que tu ailles
me chercher quelque chose.
Je sens un frisson
me parcourir.
Pose ce plateau,
et va dans ma chambre
chercher mon châle.
Tu le trouveras sur mon lit.
Oui, ma Reine.
Nous apportons
des nouvelles au Roi !
Laissez-nous passer !
Mère,
j'ai fait un vilain cauchemar !
Calme-toi, mon fils.
Je suis là, maintenant.
Fais de beaux rêves,
mon Prince.
Maintenant !
Non, je vous en supplie !
Vous ne comprenez pas !
La Reine veut ma mort !
Gardes !
Arrêtez ces hommes !
Ils sont mêlés à un complot
visant à tuer le Roi !
C'est un mensonge infamant !
Arrêtez !
Votre Majesté ?
Je suis votre dévouée servante !
Je ne leur ai rien dit,
je le jure !
Ils m'ont amenée de force
au palais !
Ayez pitié !
Emmenez-les !
Qu'ils soient exécutés !
Votre Majesté !
Ne serait-il pas avisé
de les emprisonner,
et d'attendre le jugement du Roi ?
Bien entendu.
Tu as raison.
Le Roi voudra les interroger
personnellement.
Enfermez-les !
Au bon vouloir de Votre Majesté.
Emmenez-les !
- Non, Ma Reine, non !
- Laissez-moi passer !
Ne me quitte pas !
Mon Roi !
Non !
Qui vous a fait ça ?
Qui a fait ça ?
Non, ne me quitte pas !
Ce n'est pas possible !
Mon fils !
- Ma Reine, non !
- Mon fils !
Mon fils !
Mon bébé !
Mon pauvre bébé !
Laissez-moi !
Je t'en prie, Seigneur Bouddha !
Délivre-moi de cette souffrance !
Voici la liste des traîtres,
responsables des meurtres
des miens.
J'exige leur mort immédiate !
Exécution !
" En cette année du Boeuf,
au premier jour de pleine lune,
Moi, le Roi...
vous fais connaître
mes dernières volontés. "
" Je lègue solennellement
tout le Royaume,
à mon fils et héritier,
le Roi Yodfa.
Sa mère, en qualité
de Reine Régente,
le guidera dans ses décisions,
jusqu'à sa maturité,
où il sera à même d'assumer
les responsabilités d'un Roi. "
Je me souviens...
La nuit dernière,
le Roi m'est apparu en rêve.
Il trônait sur le dos...
de l'éléphant le plus imposant
et du blanc le plus pur,
que j'aie jamais vu !
Derrière lui,
mon fils bien-aimé
était assis.
Il m'a dit...
qu'avant que lui et Yodfa,
ne rejoignent l'Éternité,
ils devaient m'aider à choisir
son successeur.
Je pourrais ainsi
mieux diriger le Royaume.
Il a désigné...
une chute d'eau étincelante,
et alors,
sorti de ce rideau de pluie...
un homme survint,
chevauchant un magnifique...
étalon blanc.
Mon époux m'a regardée,
et a dit...
" Voici l'homme...
que j'ai choisi
pour me succéder. "
Cet homme, c'était...
Vous !
Kun Chinaran !
Seigneur Bouddha !
Moi ?
Est-ce bien moi ?
- C'est bien vous.
- Moi ?
Oui, vous !
Je sais maintenant...
ce que mon défunt mari
attend de moi,
pour perpétuer
la gloire du Royaume !
Longue vie au Roi !
Vive le Roi !
Papa !... Papa !
Que fais-tu au cachot ?
Ne me touche pas !
- Papa !
- Ne pleurez pas.
Ne touchez pas à mes enfants !
Allez retrouver votre mère !
Silence !
Lâche le petit !
- Maria ?
- Ça ne te suffit pas ?
Tu as détruit
tout espoir de vie pour moi.
Quelle ironie !
Je t'ai sauvé d'un destin
pire que la mort,
et tu m'offres la mort
pour destin !
Nous sommes innocents
tous les deux.
Si je suis innocente,
explique-moi pourquoi
je suis arrêtée...
comme conspiratrice
dans la mort du Roi !
C'est la Reine !
Maria...
Elle a loué
les services de ton père.
C'est elle qui voulait
la mort du Roi.
Mon père était ce qu'on voudra,
mais un laquais de la Reine,
et un meurtrier,
certainement pas !
Je l'aimais de toute mon âme !
Lui aussi, t'aimait très fort.
Tout comme moi.
Il m'a donné ceci
avant de mourir.
Elle appartenait à ta mère.
Il m'a demandé de te la remettre.
" Pour ajouter à l'agrément
de ces festivités,
en l'honneur de Leurs Majestés,
nous allons assister
à un combat à mort...
entre deux prisonniers,
Tong, et le portugais De Gama.
Lesquels, parmi d'autres...
ont conspiré pour l'assassinat
de notre défunt Roi !
Le vainqueur...
gagnera une mort rapide
et sans douleur,
ainsi que ses proches.
Le vaincu...
aura une mort lente
dans d'atroces souffrances,
ainsi que sa famille.
Telle est l'expression
de la sagesse et de la clémence,
de votre Roi ! "
Prenez vos armes,
et battez-vous en hommes !
Ou j'envoie chercher
ceux qui vous sont chers...
immédiatement !
Combattez-vous !
Toi, pour Maria.
Moi pour ma femme,
et mes enfants !
Amenez leurs familles !
Amenez-les !
À l'aide !
Non, lâchez-moi !
Et maintenant...
Voici un genre de divertissement,
que vous n'oublierez jamais !
Ne le tuez pas !
C'est ça, battez-vous !
Tue-le !
Oui !
À nous !
À l'aide !
Qu'ont-ils fait ?
Phan, non !
Reste avec moi !
Tout devient sombre !
Tuez-les !
Attendez !
Maintenez-les !
Je descends dans l'arène !
Je veux les tuer de mes mains !
Vous deux...
je vais vous mettre en pièces !
Cela suffit !
Prince Chakkraphat ?
Gens de mon peuple...
écoutez-moi !
J'ai chevauché jusqu'ici...
à l'annonce de la mort
de mon frère et de mon neveu !
Tués de la main
d'un cruel assassin !
J'ai appris que vous aviez tiré
un manant du ruisseau,
pour l'élever au rang de Roi !
Avouez-le !
C'est vous qui avez tué
mon frère et son fils !
Et je vous accorde
une mort rapide.
Comment aurais-je pu tuer
mes propres mari et fils ?
Quelle preuve avez-vous ?
Sur l'âme de mon défunt époux,
je suis innocente !
Nous avons trouvé ceci,
au lieu indiqué par la servante.
Dans le vase de la Reine.
Vous vouliez une preuve ?
La voici, votre preuve !
Je jure...
n'avoir jamais vu cette enveloppe !
Emmenez-la !
Et tranchez-lui la gorge !
Quand ce sera fait,
empalez-la aux portes de la ville,
pour que chacun sache...
que ce jour,
justice a été rendue !
Lâchez-moi,
je suis votre Reine !
Vous ne pouvez me traiter ainsi !
M'entendez-vous, Chakkraphat ?
Vous pensez m'avoir
réduite à néant ?
Nous allons voir !
Je vous maudis pour l'Éternité !
M'entendez-vous ?
Pour l'Éternité !
Papa !
- Papa, j'ai eu si peur !
- Dieu merci, tu es sauf !
Papa, je t'aime très fort !
J'ai cru ne jamais te revoir !
On rentre à la maison ?
- S'il te plaît, maman ?
- Oui, les enfants...
- nous rentrons.
- Oui, à la maison !
Sous-titres: Studios de Saint Maur
Adaptation: Laure Hurlin